good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Thursday
I am humbled and honored to be joined by
one of I say this about everyone but
like I really mean it with you my
favorite guest co-host check Jackie is
out today and my queen Taylor strecker
hey girl hey
stunning oh my God I'm so happy to be
back the fomo I felt last week I just
want everyone to know I was invited I
was away yes okay I knew you were gonna
say that Taylor is always one of my
first it's like literally Ben Margo and
Taylor it's like family thank you and
Taylor was unavailable last week but it
was good we got to get some other people
on the couch
but you're back now
you were jealous I love all the people I
know I'm not saying it's okay to be
jealousy is like such a normalized
jealousy let's normalize jealousy I'm a
jealous girl there's not one thing that
goes on on the internet that I'm not
jealous of like I see people hanging out
I'm jealous I see people working with
Brent's jealous I see people getting
opportunities jealous I am jealous I'm a
fiercely like competitive and jealous
person me too and I'm psychotic with my
wife I had the worst dream last night
that she cheated on me okay again you
know we've been friends now I was trying
to do the math for like eight years and
I have only recently learned that you
are like a crazy psychotic jealous wife
and by the way I'm a jealous person like
crazy but when it comes to bed I'm
actually like not at all you know I envy
that because like and this is the thing
is take it so personally insulted right
because she's what do you like of me
yeah but it's I think it's because I'm
so and not that you're not obsessed with
Ben but like you know what it is I know
what it is okay I truly feel like I'm a
lazy only for Ty right but like I'm so
deep in it now that like what would I do
I know so you know what I feel like you
need some sort of reality check Taylor
like you are a lesbian like it's okay
it's cool it's good I know you're in
denial
oh I'm aware I don't know I just like I
just don't know what I would do well you
know you don't have to do anything she
loves you very much
she loves you she's not going anywhere
like you're okay maybe it's because
because I was divorced I'm like marriage
mean [__] you have trauma for sure you
carry around with you I have firing
trauma you do I have divorce trauma I
have cancellation trauma it's okay we
all love our things yes it's gonna be
okay I love you I'm so excited that
you're here you weren't here last week
but it's not because you were just like
Dilly tallying getting drunk I mean I'm
sure you were getting drunk but you were
working you were out all week last week
you were on tour you are opening for
stassi Schroeder everyone here loves
Tossy on her tour tell me about that
it's so great so last week was our first
like leg is that what we call them legs
so like on any given tour you have like
x amount of shows so we I think have I
think we're up to like 27 shows at this
point we keep adding new dates stassi's
gonna work up until her third trimester
right so thank God she's pregnant
otherwise she wouldn't stop there would
be no end in sight right and I love her
and I love working with her but like it
is Road life is exhausting it's not
fabulous list like people think it is I
mean and Stasi even is quite bougie we
see very nice hotels you you can't even
enjoy it you're you're in you're out
you're in your outside like when you're
there before the show like you're having
terrible anxieties you can't even enjoy
like the beautiful hotel nope and then
once you're there you're done and you
want to celebrate you got to move on to
the next show yeah you can't even but
your adrenaline is like kicking in yeah
so Stocky's like a very good check some
balance for me and Beau because we'll
stay up till like three in the morning I
know you will drinking and she's like
[__] get out of my room I have been
telling you I'm like I really have been
wanting you to get into stand up because
I feel like it's definitely a skill that
not everyone has and I think that you
really could do it you know first of all
it means the world second of all
I'm like letting myself believe you no I
really I don't say things just to be
nice I literally no you don't no like
I'm not I'll tell you when you do bad
like you know tell everybody what you
said to me okay okay so we go on tour we
started in Minneapolis Vibe yeah I had
no idea two nights in Chicago
incredible and then two nights in Royal
I'm sorry two shows in Royal Oak a
matinee right and then a night show
matinees are brutal but the audience was
fantastic we were just dying because we
were so tired we did five Royal Oak was
great too five shows in four days
psychotic so on the first night like I
felt so invested in your journey so
sweet I just I wanted to be there so bad
because I felt like we went through over
your material a lot and I felt like I
was in part of it like I really wanted
to know how it went so Taylor recorded
her first set and sent me it as a voice
note afterwards and I was like I was
prepared to give you like like bad notes
like what were you thinking like for
real real so I've never seen you perform
yeah
um and my first kind of intro into
seeing you do any sort of like live
performance stand up was when we were in
Lisbon Portugal for Brian's birthday on
the final night of his big party he
rented out a club and we did the roast
of Brian Kelly and Brian asked a bunch
of people from different parts of his
life to roast him and I said no you did
say no and I wanted you to do it like I
pushed you I said I said Brian wants you
to do it even though Brian was okay with
you canceling I wanted you to push
yourself like I know that you can do it
like I really can but
so
in Lisbon Taylor was not great and I
would never have said anything I told
you you did great what's the point in
making someone like feel like [__] it's
over I know but like I embarrassed
myself in front of all of our friends
who didn't embarrass you any yourself I
was the worst you were um I was the
worst I was the worst you weren't the
worst
but whatever so honestly that was like
oh damn maybe like maybe I saw something
in her that wasn't there maybe I was
just seeing things and then she sent me
her voice memo from her first
performance and you were just amazing I
love you I was so shocked you sounded so
confident you sounded like a comic who's
been doing this for 40 years and maybe
it was just like your smoker's cough
that gave you that sort of edge but you
were incredible you were so confident
you were so funny and like I knew what
you were you know memorized to say and I
know that you were adding stuff and you
didn't seem nervous at all and then I
felt comfortable telling you that you
stunk it up and listen because that
didn't really matter that wasn't a paid
gig or anything it didn't I will say
this I was out of my element in Lisbon
because I'm not good at roast I'm good
at making fun of me yes I'm very bad at
making fun of other people I hate it
such a fair Affair critique because say
my whole brand of Comedy is just making
fun of myself because you know what
everyone's so sensitive so so if I'm
making fun of myself nobody can be mad
and Brian's like Brian can hang he's fun
he's tough but like I
Brian like if you cross a line it could
be like random like you made a joke
about the river and even afterwards like
weeks after he was like but do you
really not like the river I know he's
very connected to the Delaware River
I know so I almost ran up to you in
Lisbon and said cut me and I knew that
we had somebody that added that night so
I was like the space is filled I
honestly regret not doing that really
but I feel like moments like that are
what like build character in a performer
and I feel like you maybe wouldn't have
crushed as hard as you did last week if
you didn't flop in Lisbon it was a
really good trial run and it like got me
get to get my [__] together because the
whole time I was getting ready for tour
was like you don't want to be like
Lisbon where it was last minute and you
were freaking out no you don't want it
to be such a long period of time since
you've been in front of a crowd so true
so you know what I feel like I made the
right choice
well thank you for the feedback I mean
all of it you were incredible I can't
I'm gonna go to your show you guys are
playing Town Hall in New York I'm
totally coming oh 100 removes my flight
because I'm going to Dallas but I'm I'm
coming home early to see it Angels I'm
so excited it's gonna be so fun that's
gonna be a nerve-wracking show though
that in LA because then it's like people
you know in the audience exactly and
like I mean by the time we get there I
think I'll know it's so inside and out
it won't matter but New York and L.A are
interesting because they're industry
towns yeah and Industry is like too cool
for school so a lot of people in the
audience especially when it's like a lot
of comps that are like agents and
managers and [__] like that you don't
get great laughs and great audience
interactions so it can be
scary I will say um on tour I would say
probably my worst performing myself like
I did the worst in La I was so panicked
been invited like so many celebrities
you know Ben he's like wheeling and
dealing of course and this whole thing
in my show about Twilight and like
literally I'm looking at Taylor Lautner
like it was horrible too much it was
hard too hard it was horrible
um before we I want to talk to you about
what we did last night but I just wanted
to remind everyone our First Merch
launch since our Rebrand happened this
morning if you go to toastmerch.com we
have new crewnecks new phone cases new
mugs I'm wearing one today this is the
teal one we've been wearing them all
week Jackie and I both wear a size large
we know you guys have been waiting for a
merch launch and we took our time with
this one because we had new logos and we
wanted to be really good and really
toasty toastmerch.com I know a bunch of
you already got your March but I just
wanted to remind you that that was today
isn't that reutered it is embroidered
thank you for noticing I'm obsessed oh
let me connect you with my embroiderer
thank you
um last night we're gonna dive into the
Fast Five but I want to talk about what
we did last night because I was floored
were you let me tell you a fun fact
about me and I don't even know if you
know this I and it's so crazy because
I'm such a show tunes girl do you hate I
hate going to the theater like I with
the exception of funny girl which I most
recently saw of course and before that
you couldn't get me to the theater for
years I saw dear Evan Hansen which was
incredible it was did you see Hamilton
no get out I know I saw it twice I like
I I just low-key like don't like going
to the theater I know that's so crazy no
I'm with you actually because well first
of all like the seats are so [__]
small was your ass killing you last
night killing and like we were in dope
scene Brian of course brought front row
tickets which is a wild experience and
very valuable given what we do for a
living because like you never really
know what it's like for people in the
front row I am it's a lot it's a lot and
I felt like my face like I wanted to be
smiling the whole time for them I didn't
want to give negative energy right like
when I'm enjoying something my mouth is
just closed and I just look like I'm
miserable but I'm enjoying it but I'm
not smiling you know but as performers
we know what that feels like on stage
yeah so I know I was like I mean I I was
getting it up for those performers I had
sat front row in a Broadway show Once
like many many many years ago me and Ben
saw um
Matilda
why
I don't know
um and the kid actors were wearing
microphones but the microphones were
taped to their yes down their hairline
and then dangled over their forehead and
it looked like this little ball sack it
was like this little flesh colored ball
and me and Ben didn't know what it was
we're like What do all these kids have
like growths on their forehead it was so
bizarre now last night they were just
wearing Mike's strap to their cheeks
which is much more normal yes
um and so just precursor saying that I
do I just like the theater like I love
show tunes and I have a lot of respect
but just as an experience I don't like
sitting in a theater no I'm actually
with you too it gives me a lot of
anxiety like especially if I'm sitting
like sitting in the middle I'm worried
about peeing I I get a lot of anxiety I
feel you and I find that like almost
every single Broadway show is 30 minutes
too long agreed I think a lot of shows
could deal with no intermission and just
doing one 90 minute show instead of two
and a half hours and let's cut all the
slow songs
um
so having said that I was definitely
like you know let's get through this I
was not like Overjoyed uh-huh to be
going to the theater we saw Anne Juliet
which is like a very modern adaptation
of Romeo and Juliet but it's told
through the lens of like what would have
happened if actually Julia didn't die
and then she goes on this journey of
self-discovery yeah and the music it's
not an original score it is set to the
music the the cat the catalog of music
of legendary pop producer Max Martin and
I'm sure a lot of you guys have never
heard of him but every song you've ever
liked in your life is Max Barton
Backstreet Boys Ariana Grande Britney
Spears in sync it's from the early 1990s
up until most recently the weekend this
is Taylor Swift he was the main producer
on 1989 by Taylor Swift oh my God he is
so like you will know every single song
I knew every single song and there was
even some like deep Cuts in there like
Domino by Jessie J like that's not a I
was obsessed I was tossed so I knew I
was gonna like the music and I was just
I was blown away
I it was amazing it was incredible and
also like the actress kept spinning on
me which I loved yeah usually I would
not like that yeah but because they were
so talented I thought maybe they'd
spittle Talent onto me it was Juliet was
insane so a major shout out to the
actress who played Juliet and who played
William Shakespeare's wife named Anne
Hathaway who knew that she was and you
know what I was thinking the whole time
I was thinking this like show reminds me
weirdly and just kind of like a lot of
the jokes reminds me of shit's creek I
know that sounds random and then I was
like get their Instagram today and the
person who wrote the show is the writer
of shit's creek no [__] isn't that crazy
not to say like I have like a you know
like some sort of like talent for like
you know whatever but I was like
especially the Anne Hathaway character
she reminded me so much of Jocelyn from
schitt's Creek yep in the way she spoke
and I was like oh it's just giving
shit's creek energy and then I was
shocked to see that it was incredible I
can't recommend it enough like it felt
like fun Hamilton it was fun yes it was
hysterical hysterical
vocals on Juliet insane that is
genuinely like what I think I sound like
when I sing like and it was nice to hear
someone like actually sound like that
you know
like that's what I think I'm like doing
all these runs on Celine Dion like
that's what I think I sound like I don't
but that's what I think I do she's
saying one song that at the end of that
note oh my God Katy Perry Roar was like
this moment at the end when Juliet like
gets to be herself or whatever and she
gets on this floating Terrace that like
floats through the theater oh my God
unbelievable I will say this too I feel
like there's not a bad seat in the
theater so get tickets uh you don't have
to be front row to enjoy it no but we
take it to stand up at the end and dance
yeah everyone was like giving me [__]
they're like you were filming at a
Broadway show at the end it was the
final song they asked everyone to get up
on their feet like it was a film
friendly and sorry I wanted to post and
support the Arts oh God people Broadway
like um etiquette like enforcers [__]
off yep I'm not like one of those people
who like falls asleep and is on their
phone the whole time like I have respect
for the theater
um also what is your take on singing
along to the songs because here's the
thing everyone knows the songs you were
like I was saying but like you were like
quiet I was that's actually a good point
point I was conscious of my volume for
sure not the lady next to me was she
like there was like three of them I
think they must have like swapped seats
during interview I saw that yes and they
were Freaks and they were like singing
loud I wanted to be like shut the [__]
up and then come here to listen to you
[__] saying oh that is annoying
annoying especially in the front row
that's probably like a little disruptive
to the performers right for sure I know
I did not love I got the eye of the
tiger of fighter dancing through the oh
my God it was so good you guys and like
I just want to say like I am not a
person who gives out compliments to
Broadway shows like I'm very particular
really like the like the last one the
shows I've seen in the last probably 10
years are this yep funny girl what you
die for and dear Evan Hansen which are
like obviously two of the biggest shows
like of the last decade yeah so I have a
high bar and so if I recommend it it's
good recommended recommended very much
so it was my birthday present from Brian
oh right and Claudette crashed because
she was gonna kill us well Claudette
crashed because I've been saying I want
to see see the show and then Taylor's
like oh Brian got me tickets for my
birthday I'm like oh what show and
Juliet uh are you [__] kidding no I
said something Juliet oh you didn't even
know you didn't even know you don't
support the arts Taylor you don't
support the Arts
so before we start I do want to say
today is Theo's birthday happy birthday
thank you it's tough you know being a
dog mom is not like a celebratory thing
when your dog has a birthday how old is
he sex that's
getting up there shut the [__] up you're
a [__] you're a [__] get out of my
studio
me and Ben cried last time before bed
yeah it's just like oh man honestly I
don't talk about it because I feel like
myself I'm sorry no no I'm old Theo's
it's it's fine you like old people
that's true I am drawn towards like more
wise older people he's like me he's over
the hill but you're a [__] [__] get
out but still but still in that's my
this is disgusting
toasters get her please God don't leave
hate comments on her Instagram at Taylor
strucker
who relate to him
you can't okay this is a dog and you're
a human
okay
so I guess without further Ado it's time
to dive into the best five stories
if we must
today's episode is brought to you by
seed seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is a
plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic with
24 strain that has been clinically or
scientifically studied for its benefits
so it's free from 14 classes of
allergens defined by the efsa it's
sugar-free vegan soy-free Sesame free
gluten-free peanut free all the freeze
dairy free shellfish free corn free corn
free if you've been looking into your
gut health and want to take charge of
your gut health definitely check out
seeds daily symbiotic you take two
capsules once a day on an empty stomach
and it's like the first thing you do in
the morning and then the last one is two
hours after your last meal and it's
engineered to survive your external and
internal environments so their capsule
and capsule safeguards viability through
digestion for delivery of an average of
a hundred percent of their probiotic
starting dose to your colon the outer
capsule serves as an elegant barrier to
oxygen moisture and heat so there's no
Refrigeration necessary
so there's so many benefits to the ds01
set daily symbiotic from seed like of
course your digestive health but also
skin Health they have four specific
probiotic strains that have been shown
to promote healthy skin and reinforce
healthy gut skin access so if you want
to take charge of your gut and your
immunity check out seeds daily ds01
symbiotic go to seed.com that's
s-eed.com toast and use code toast to
redeem 25 off your first month of the
ds01 daily symbiotic so that's seed.com
toast use code toast today's episode is
also brought to you by Starbucks ready
to drink coffee life moves fast
Starbucks ready to drink coffee delivers
an uplifting boost that helps you tune
in the moments that matter wherever you
are so it's Starbucks coffee but it's
conveniently packaged for a life on the
go they include a variety of beverages
like the bottled Frappuccino chilled
coffee drink that one has a nice pop of
flavor it's very bold they also have the
smooth Taste of the Nitro cold brew
which I'm sure you love getting at
Starbucks and now they have it on the go
we have a ton in our studio canned
beverages are just so easy to go on the
go grab it on your way out on your way
in we know the Starbucks drinks are so
delicious and now you can get them from
the comfort of your own home the bottled
Frappuccino coffee drink is inspired by
the Starbucks cafe favorites and they
come in four delicious flavors mocha
vanilla caramel and coffee you can enjoy
every moment with Starbucks ready to
drink coffee you know Jackson and I are
business women we don't have time to
just be Dilly dallying waiting in line
for beverages but you know what we know
you're busy too your mothers your
daughters your sons you're all so busy
you're working girls your girls are on
the go your stay-at-home moms can't get
out of the house make sure you're
bringing these delicious beverages to
your home Starbucks coffee it's ready
for right now shop the full lineup
online or in store wherever you buy
groceries
all right first story we actually have
an update from something Jack and I
spoke about earlier in the week so I
don't know if you've been keeping up
with the Coachella drama a little bit
I'm not really a Coachella girly I'm
aware yeah neither am I but Frank Ocean
was the headliner there's two weekends
of Coachella one was last weekend one
was this weekend right he was the big
headliner final act on Sunday night he
stunk up the place he cut his set short
he literally was like sorry it's curfew
I gotta go no he stood there like with
his music playing on an aux cord and
like didn't even sing there was like
dancers standing right in front of him
people couldn't see him what it was very
people were really upset because he's
like a lot of big a lot of huge fans and
he hasn't performed live in many years
and this was supposed to be like a big
deal I guess this is why I guess this is
why and now he has dropped out for a
weekend too that's psychotic first of
all contractually can he even do that he
will be losing a ton of money I don't
even know if now they have to pay him
for the first one that's crazy I mean
think about this like how much money is
on the table Millions so I think last I
heard Headliners get paid like six
million dollars for two performances
wow man just go out there and like make
fart noises [__] just do it I can't what
think about what would be going on that
you're like I simply cannot unless it
was like a death in the family like you
just go or like a medical emergency but
like don't you think that they would say
that it was no but and that's what I was
saying last week like even some sort of
like medical emergency like Beyonce she
had a broken leg she would do it abso
[__] lutely you know
um so not only has he dropped out which
is a kind of a crazy historic thing that
hasn't really happened they have
replaced Frank Ocean with blink 182. oh
don't tell Ben and Tay I know they're
gonna wanna they're literally gonna get
flights they're gonna drag us there well
so Blink 182 actually performed at
Coachella last weekend as a not a
headliner like during the day so I don't
know I mean I think they're an equal
replacement like I think the people who
go to Coachella will love Blink 182
right
um but I wouldn't be surprised if people
like demand
refunds because I think a lot of people
bought tickets to just for Frank Ocean
and if you're like a major Frank Ocean
fan I don't think there's a lot of
crossover between blink 182. I would go
to all the shows and then I would demand
a refund yeah of course of course of
course of course I by the way and I saw
blink 182's performance at Coachella
like they're very good and it's Travis
Barker yeah but like it doesn't give me
headliner Vibes I know it gives me
headliner Vibes for like a 90s Festival
yes not for coachelli no I was really
shocked to see that he um
he so his reasoning for not performing
so he said after suffering suffering an
injury to his leg on the festival
grounds in the week leading up to the
show Frank Ocean was unable to perform
the intended show last weekend but was
still intent on performing for the
second weekend but in 72 hours the show
was reworked out of necessity so the
doctor's advice is that the artist is
not able to perform weekend two due to
two fractures and a sprain in his left
leg wimp so that's the the line they're
going with on
a sprain yeah so this is a Frank Ocean
added a statement saying it was chaotic
there was some beauty and Chaos it isn't
what I intended to show but I did enjoy
being out there and I'll see you all
soon so he's admitting that he kind of
flopped and he's blaming the leg
that's weak sauce yeah
and also it doesn't like really bode
well for the future of his career I just
don't know if a lot of people are going
to feel confident booking him for for
festivals I have a confession
I don't think I know one Frank Ocean
song You're Not Alone really I don't
think I know one either I don't even
think I know what it looks like I do
he's extremely handsome and cute and um
in that case I take back everything I
said and I've by the way I've heard him
perform like songs and he isn't like I
get he's hyped up for a reason like he
is an incredible singing voice and he's
an extremely talented songwriter
um and this there's a reason why after
six years people are like dying and
there's been a very high bar when you've
waited that long you know I think I
understand now why he bailed out he has
pretty privilege we know what that's
like because we have pretty privilege
too
we're two beautiful women who are
constantly just being given
opportunities just because of our looks
and not because of our talent I feel
like he was like he's not used to
failing because he's so beautiful yeah
and he's not used to people telling him
that he like sucked right like the way
that you told me I sucked in Lisbon like
he couldn't handle that sucked I just
what did I say
stunk up the place yeah I feel like
that's inaccurate representation I'm
sorry
so yeah would you ever go to Coachella
literally never you're like the
antithesis of Coachella in my mind me
too sounds like hell although I do love
a jam band not the coachella's that but
like I was once upon a time a festival
girly you were yeah I slept in tents I
went to mow down what I did the drug
what's mow down I don't know I was
invited is it a festival yeah it's a I
think it's a band called Mo and it was a
town just Mo and it was a festival with
like other bands it's like it gives like
fish Vibes got it got it got it yeah
okay tell me about you camping not well
I have my period so let's not even I
feel like Liam McSweeney in Real
Housewives ultimate girls trip no but
you know what that's an important fact
for like why you didn't have a good time
horrible camping with your period a bear
would come and eat your vagina literally
well luckily I was protected by piles of
poop so it was fine it was a nightmare
oh there was like the porta potties were
overflowing right people were on like so
messed up on drugs that were just taking
shits wherever they please Woodstock
energy I brought my Taylor Guitar my mom
bought me for Christmas how old were you
I was like 18 or 19. oh okay okay
because like I could not see any version
of you that I currently know even
thinking about doing that so like
freshman year of college I like had a
lot of identities and this is one of
them it was my hippie girl identity and
it did not survive I literally left
there and I was like everybody just came
with I absolutely never want to see
again never again can I ask you a
question that might be a little personal
I'm just curious because I've never
asked you and you know I love to ask you
like invasive questions about you and
Tay yes when you were in college did you
ever have an experimental phase never
really I never even kissed a girl before
Tay like seriously I kissed my friend
Leah senior year no junior year of
college for Pita Pit because we were so
hungry and we were so broke we had no
money left and the boys that we hung out
with were like if you guys kiss we'll
buy Pita Pit for you which is very
problematic looking back boys are so
deeply disgusting and unwell so we did
it and then we get the pita I got the
Pita Pit I got extra feta I got an extra
pick are you for real I don't know the
greatest thing on the face of the planet
what is it it's just Peter we [__]
inside but it's so good lately I picked
the name of the institution yes Pita Pit
and then you get the pita it's like you
you just like create your own build your
own no I get it it's like it's rarely
food so but yeah Pita Pit is the name of
the restaurant by your college yes why
the [__] would I know that it's well
it's a chain oh it's a chain yes yes do
they have one in the city should we go I
don't think it exists anymore damn but
we should try to find one we could drive
to Upstate New York and my personal
college experience similar was called
University Peta okay and it was like it
wasn't even a restaurant it was
literally a window in the wall like you
would it was on the street like you
literally walk on the street and you
look to your right and the man is
standing in the window and it was like
this hole in the wall you could there
was nowhere to sit and you would just
get the most amazing schnitzel Shawarma
lava Pita and it was kosher so like we
ate that [__] and they closed shortly
after like my freshman or sophomore year
and it was devastating for the community
rest in peace bring back University Peta
and for sure we would call it you pita
oh my God it's so cool
[Laughter]
you just fell
so cool
NYU kids were doing at the time were you
cool knowledge
I literally lived at home the last three
years of college I recently learned this
yes my college experience was I don't
even like to call it College you know my
freshman year like I tried I lived in
the dorms
I tried but the thing is like I went to
college with so many of my friends from
high school because I went to high
school in the city so like Abe who you
know yeah my best friends from college
were just my best friends from high
school but I did make one friend Margot
fish
um she was a college friend but she like
she went to a Jewish High School in New
Jersey like it really wasn't that crazy
and I didn't really go out I didn't like
have a lot of colleges and then I met
Ben so my last three years of college I
moved at home and just hung out with Ben
Honestly though you were building like a
brand right the way I'm so jealous of
your college experience being like
oncology well see it's both because I
feel like I don't think I would be at
the place I'm at now in terms of career
if I didn't like just waste away those
last three years of college like
building a brand instead of like going
out yes but now I'm very much like
living my college Years in terms of
partying like I don't party at all in
college when I got out of college and I
was like hanging out with Jackie and
Jackie's friends and you and Brian like
that's when I became like I act like of
college freshman when I go out yeah but
growing up but I did the college thing
and I'm still acting like it yeah well
you're deeply problematic
facts nobody on this planet can hold
their liquor better than you it's beyond
impressive well lately I've been a
little bit more of like a a wimp when it
comes to my drinking in a good way like
I'm embracing it like last night I had a
martini did I finish it no the answer is
no I had a glass of sincere did I finish
that yes the answer is yes and then
Brian ordered me like a vodka I had like
three sips and then the thing I got
Scotch and Soda Scotch and Soda double
but I didn't finish it baby steps also
at the Broadway show last night Taylor
was very generous to be the one to get
drinks during excuse me intermission yes
and she brought me a tequila soda that
was made with poison and I took one Sip
and I was like I don't think I can do
this and then I'm like watching the show
and I'm getting [__] itchy I look
down I have hives on my arm I know are
they still there my throat was really
scratchy I went home and took a Benadryl
I was like actually kind of freaked out
I don't know what the tequila brand was
it was definitely like Jose Cuervo it
was just giving me like hives isn't that
crazy awful I'm sorry well I would go
camping with you by the way I think that
would be only if we could like Vlog it
I'm sewing let's go like someplace
fabulous cell like a Glam yes but
glamping is still camping if you have to
like leave a lot tent and go even to a
like bathroom that has Plumbing but you
have to walk outside yeah that's
dangerous we should go let's do it but
one night only okay fine we can go up to
Ithaca they have glamped and we can get
peed up here if we get Pita Pit I also
just like like candy because I really
weirdly like the food that goes along
with camping like hot dogs Moors and
like grilling yes I like a hamburger
what really do you eat yeah no like I
just like the smells of of camping does
that make sense yes it does like and I
love nature I would love to like look at
the stars with you okay I'm in okay
let's do it all right next up and I just
realized I don't know this about you so
are you a Twilight girl at all I
actually am again I feel like I'm a
little like aged out of like the
obsessive yes that's fair but I was
working it serious I think when it came
out and so I was like in it because it
was like Twilight Mania right so I get
it and I didn't hate the movies no I was
absolutely head over heels in love like
literally can't watch them enough times
obsessed would quite literally do
anything to spend one night with Robert
Pattinson okay so we're different in
that way
because you're a lesbian no why are you
Jacob no I'm not like sexually attracted
to any of the vampires or werewolves
what about Carlisle he's a nice like
older gentleman no I just it maybe
Kristen Stewart
that makes sense okay well there is a
Twilight TV series that now is in the
works the Twilight Saga is getting the
television treatment at sources tell The
Hollywood Reporter that a series version
of all the author's uh best-selling book
series is in early development at
Lionsgate so why I don't know they have
great people attached to it like the
writer of tell me lies The Walking Dead
but they're working with Lion's gate to
determine what the specific take on
Twilight will be and if it will be a
remake of Stephanie Myers's original
books or a different offshoot so they
don't know what they're doing but
they're trying to make a TV show that's
somehow loosely associated with Twilight
well listen they made The Last of Us
based off of a freaking video game it
was the best thing ever let me watch it
oh I love it and I'm not really into
apocalyptic neither am I like I never
watched The Walking Dead I was really
into it give it a shot the first episode
kind of a little heavy be like and then
it gets good well so this TV show like
this news must have just gotten late
because it doesn't have a network or a
platform yet or apparently any sort of
creative concept but a lot of people are
like well why the [__] do we need a TV
show about Twilight when there's five
books and five movies like this just
seems like a money grab because we can
never get enough of [__] I know and it's
like Twilight is perfect the movies were
perfect I wouldn't touch a hair on their
head you know I'm also concerned about
the tell me lies uh writer you didn't
like it I mean I watched it and I was
obsessed with it but it's [__] it's
terrible oh I love me and Jackie loved
yeah but love and like this is bad no no
and we and there is no writing and I
attacks um it was also a book so it's
like what did you write what did they
write but I loved it like I was obsessed
not in a bad way no I was obsessed but
it was like a little bit of like a ROM
at the end well it was a big shocker too
and there's another season well I'm in
I'm gonna watch the second yeah it was
so like you know the show sex lives yeah
like that season I was so into would you
watch the second season I had to stop I
felt like I was taking acid I was
humiliated to be watching was it okay I
was watching I watched it on the plane
to Lisbon oh my God honestly I had time
I had to literally hide my iPad because
it's quite literally porn and the first
season was porn but like it had a heart
and it had like good stories and good
writing yeah this was humiliating like I
was embarrassed to be watching it and
all I could think was The Season's such
a like a stinker and like she blew her
entire life up the lead yeah to be with
the male lead and by the way do you know
who she was married to before yes but
I'm forgetting Steve Howey from Reba
really he's also from Shameless but yes
yes
I love it I don't think he's so hot so
hot she blew it and yeah this guy Adam's
cute and like maybe if that dick was
prosthetic or not like he has a big
penis like who [__] cares no and like
they have like a family like everything
I know and I feel like I understand like
working with somebody and having this
like chemistry chemistry and then also
the show was like this massive success
and you're like we're gonna be the
couple forever like wait till season two
to like pull they still together
I think so I think so too though she has
to be together with him forever I don't
know after this season it was like Gili
level Steve howey's so hot I am
available dude no and he gets like
better looking with age oh I'm obsessed
with him me too oh my God he's a big
Burly man yeah yeah yeah speaking of big
Burly men yeah oh my God Jen fessler
real houses in New Jersey I'm not caught
up but continue having sex with Tony
Soprano wait do you know the way wait
James Gandolfini you got it yep years
ago she was a talent agent and by the
way I'm obsessed with Jen fessler and
she should be first of all Jackie
goldstrander keeps getting so much
screen time and she's in [__]
sufferable and Jen fessler deserves this
the screen time continue
I mean do you know that Tony Soprano is
my number one no I didn't know that if I
had a hall pass I mean I should probably
use it to someone who's alive right but
my God the jealousy that was like
seething out of my pores when she said
that and she slept with it more than
once we reported this yesterday Teddy
Mellencamp said uh she revealed that she
had a one night stand with Matt Damon I
know so that brings up I was trying to
think other Housewives have said Carol
bradswell had sex with George Clooney or
she went on a date with him I can't
remember which one I'm dead now we have
Jen fessler and Tony Soprano and we have
Matt Damon and Teddy Mellencamp yes
that's pretty good I'm really proud of
our Housewives
um
but James Gandolfini is like your big
Burly man of choice number one I would
go with like Jason Momoa in terms of big
whirlyman and honestly I feel like you
might like him because he kind of looks
like a woman with his long hair you know
who it says doppelganger it pains me to
admit cause he's so hot sheena's husband
Brock oh she and his Husband Brock is
cute but you know he cut his hair no
yeah
well actually that brings me that's a
good oh no I don't have a Vanderpump
roll story I thought I did I mean we
didn't watch last night because we were
out at the theater it's on it doesn't
come out today Thursday yesterday
Wednesdays I'm such an idiot damn it no
that's okay yeah I got my days mixed up
um but back to this Twilight thing I
just wanted to say really quickly like I
take Twilight really seriously because
like how Ariana madix takes sketch
comedy really seriously oh my God I'm
dead
I feel like the legacy of Twilight is so
protected and so many people make movies
out of books and it's crap and it like
ruins it is perfect and I it need not be
touched yes I don't even want a reunion
between the cast I want nothing I get it
I understand it like just keep it sacred
and I'm protective over it because it's
weirdly like a franchise that means a
lot to me and I will read the books one
day but I I need everyone to stop okay
and I'm happy for Stephanie Meyer
because like she just wrote these weird
books and ended up a billionaire and I
love that for her yes she had to be in
the fifth movie she was like a wedding
guest and everyone was like oh my God
it's Stephanie but she needs to stop
yeah enough it's enough enough's enough
like just be happy with what you haven't
read something new stop milking it she
did by the way and what she did write
was um it was kind of like a prequel
told from the perspective the whole book
is told from the POV of Bella right but
now she wrote like a prequel from the
POV of Edward and people love loved it
I'm gonna do something with that but
like leave the books alone it sounds
like Anne Juliet it sounds like an
Juliet
today's episode is brought to you by
Lululemon their new align collection
which I am very proudly wearing today
the mini high-rise Flair pant is
everything of the sword so Lululemon is
known for their fabulous clothing and
this aligned collection is really taking
it to another level so for me the main
reason I'm obsessed with this collection
is the flexibility the four-way stretch
means that you can bend you can stretch
you can move literally any way you want
to without restriction or distraction or
is that like an uncomfortable band
digging into your stomach I've been
wearing these pants I'm sure you guys
know quite literally every day on the
toast and I am obsessed they're really
comfortable they're made with nulu
fabric for the softest comfiest texture
your legs have ever felt period and the
fit so it shapes perfectly to your body
for a really flattering look that fits a
body that's Uniquely Yours so these
pants are going to look different on
everyone because they're going to make
you look your best I love the way I look
in these pants like these are that like
I said high-rise mini flare legging
obsessed beyond belief I look like I'm
going look I could be going anywhere am
I going to a business meeting or am I
going to the airport you'll never know
because I'm keeping you on your toes
they're weightless it has a
lightweightless sensation that feels
like you're wearing nothing and nothing
else so I love this collection you
should check it out get into the
Lululemon align collection at
lululemon.com that's l-u-l-u lemon.com
today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death all right you might have
seen these cans All Around Town liquid
death is the Premier water brand you've
maybe heard us talk about their Mountain
Water and their flavored Sparkling
Waters that look just like tall boys of
beer now they have a new line of iced
tea that we love the taste is
truly stunning there are three flavors
of the iced tea one is the Grim leafer
the other is rest in Peach and armless
Palmer so the names are really cute the
flavors are really good I love the rest
in Peach I love a peach tea we have them
in the studio perfect to do while I'm
toasting after the toast before during
after there's never a bad time to have a
tea from liquid death is basically what
I'm trying to say
um it's a really fabulous brand because
their packaging is so cute everyone's
gonna think you're like getting wasted
but you're actually just at work sipping
on a tea because you're a responsible
adult even though maybe you'd rather be
out at the bar maybe you would be
um liquid deaths new Iced Teas are
available now with free shipping on
Amazon and retailers near you as an
added bonus the toast listeners get 20
off their first liquid death apparel
purchase available exclusively at
liquiddeath.com toast exclusions May
apply that's liquiddeath.com
t-o-a-s-t and maybe just scare someone
in your life you know maybe just be
driving with a liquid death and let
everyone think like oh she's crazy but
she's just drinking a delicious tea
perhaps it's the peach flavor who knows
enjoy liquiddeath.com toast to get 20
off your first liquid death apparel
purchase it's available exclusively at
liquiddeath.com toast okay you ready for
our next story yes please are you caught
up with Love's blind I am okay I know
your wife is obsessed so I don't know if
you were Khloe Kardashian is considering
going on love is blind with her single
sisters so Khloe Kardashian joked about
wanting her and her single sisters to go
on the Netflix date and show love is
blind she posted on Instagram I guess
she had like a good American event and
Alexa from last season the Israeli Queen
obsessed to marry the country Cowboy yep
and I just like did an Instagram stock
of them just to make sure they were
still happy and they are
um so she posted like a carousel it was
kind of crazy she did an in-feed
Carousel of just three pictures with
Alexa no other people no other promo for
the event just gave Alexa like her own
time to shine fangirl and she wrote I
think some of us single K sisters should
go on lib what do you think yes in oh my
God it would be incredible but that
would have to be its own entire spin-off
I know that she it would [__] it up no
because their voices are so recognizable
totally but like conceptually and I
think they would never but like to do a
dating show where they get to do like
the Love is Blind thing but nobody knows
they're famous and they get to like
really see people for who they are what
if they did like a spin-off or they did
like love is blind and voice boxes well
Ben has the funniest idea that they
should do the opposite of Love is Blind
Called Love is shallow where you just
like look at someone through her window
and like you can't hear them and you
just like try to communicate and you
just pick someone based off their looks
without them ever opening their mouth
honestly I feel like it might work I
think it will be brilliant and Netflix
is always coming up with these like dumb
dating shows you know love is blind is
everything this season hands down like
if you haven't watched I was blind like
this is the one to get into no the first
season is I think the best it'll ever be
because nobody knew what the show was
and there were definitely people who
came on the show to get famous Zach and
like they're using the platform right
what it is but this was like nobody knew
what the [__] it was everybody on that
first season barely any of them are
famous like except for the couples that
got married and they were not thirsty
they were just regular people like doing
this weird love experiment when you say
Zach you mean season four Zach what do
you mean season four Zach no how dare
you he said for Love is Blind what Bliss
are perfect no he just got lucky because
they were both so desperate for love
like they sorry I'm not gonna like
exactly whatever Zack would have gone
with anyone and Bliss like was like all
right sure Bliss is an angel Center
thank God for him but they're both
incredibly desperate people yes that's
why it worked yes and I think they have
a very happy life together and I don't
mean that in a negative way yeah but
they only got together because they were
desperate because I think a lot of other
girls would have been too proud to go
with somebody who chose someone else
absolutely and some people would not
have the shame that Zach had the balls
to go yeah I chose the wrong girl but
you want to get married oh Zach ugh I
have a special place in my heart and
Zach is over here like accusing Irina
wanting to go on the show for famous and
Zach is calling tianzia on himself at
the airport and posting the clips on his
Instagram stop he does give homicidal
vibes
it was like I'm not saying I was like
scared I was like just say it he's
freaky he gives you murder Vibes it's
okay it's okay I think he's okay he's
nice I don't think he'll murder Bliss
well we'll just have to wait I hope not
you know they say when a woman is
murdered the first almost primary
suspect is always a husband I don't know
he gives me more like sneak out in the
middle of the night and like like be a
serial killer kill dogs on the side yeah
but that's until he escalates to people
thank you
I really do like him I really don't
actually I think like he was playing
such the victim card to the point where
he became the villain like he was loving
being the victim because Irina was mean
to him and it's like she was mean for
sure so what about Micah and Paul like I
couldn't figure out me neither I don't
really care he hates her I know I kind
of like Micah I think I like Micah too I
hated her at the beginning with the
whole Irina thing me too but I also like
Paul by the way I don't really take a
side I think it's fair for like Paul to
not have wanted to marry her because she
didn't have certain qualities that he
was looking for and he didn't have to
say that to her because it would have
been mean like I know I think it's fine
yeah but then if he was gonna say to her
in person he shouldn't say it at the
reunion well Vanessa like literally was
forcing him she was what are your
thoughts there's this petition going
around it has like 30 000 signatures now
about like people are hating Nick and
Vanessa so Nick needs to just Nick
you're gone like Vanessa was in control
the whole time and she has been for Four
Seasons straight yeah so just like he
like he is offering nothing so he brings
absolutely nothing to the table I'm Nick
Lachey obviously remember season
dude you don't even say three words
right Vanessa okay first of all stop
giving her teleprompter with cheesy ass
lines having been in a hosting position
where there's a script half the time
painful it can kill your soul yeah I
don't think that that's her fault
necessarily but she's not like funny
and when she tries to be funny makes her
not likable and she laughs at her own
jokes and nobody else does oh my God no
I do that too but like we're funny you
know but I liked like two-thirds in
because Tay was watching the plane and
she um was texting me like this is
painful and I was like was just get
through the first third and then the
second like two thirds in like it's
gonna be great yeah Vanessa was asking
really good questions was she biased
yeah but like [__] it she she's a fan
she's also part of the show like she has
opinions I liked her own questions when
she was not on teleprompter okay that's
fair yeah I thought like the reunion was
really terrible but not because of
Vanessa because
it was live yes so these people who are
just
Beyond average were not edited and like
my God were they long-winded Marshall
and Zach like they were just they're
average people and that's what makes a
show great but that's why they need to
be edited they're not you know brilliant
thinkers why didn't Netflix think to go
live just like they're trying to get a
new thing live like they had the live
Chris Rock special which was actually
pretty great yep
um they're they're coming for cable like
they're literally Jackie was saying it's
so smart they're reverting back to Cable
that's psychotic now they're live they
ruined cable they ruined cable but
they're streaming and now they want to
go back to Cable right because they
don't even drop full seasons anymore
they drop two episodes two episodes two
episodes right they're literally
reverting back to their no yeah it's
annoying they can't do this no it's
terrible okay um so who is like your
favorite couple from Love is Blind ever
I mean everyone says like uh Cameron and
Lauren and I agree but Alexa and Brendan
from last season who Chloe posted with
like I'm obsessed with
um cowboy and Israeli I am they're my
favorite I'm sorry she is such a Vibe
she was so cool and I just love that she
was like so unapologetically herself
yeah she's like yeah I'm really bougie
like this is how I am like we're gonna
have to live like this and Brandon just
like Brandon was like a character out of
a book like he was like okay whatever
you want like what like he'll just get a
ton I'm obsessed her confidence like she
is my role model I love her I love her
agreed
um all right a little Katy Perry news
Katy Perry has been acting like an
absolute animal on American Idol I'm
like it doesn't go unnoticed she's been
like making contestants cry and Katy
Perry was booed this week on American
Idol because she criticized a
contestant's outfit
so a top 26 contestant named nutsa was
performing a Grace Potter song in a
sparkly silver dress and Katy Perry who
judges the competition show told her
that she needed to lay off of her
signature glittery look she said nutsa
every time you take the stage it's like
you glitter bomb the stage listen one
thing I would like to see from you is
not one piece of glitter the next time
on stage I know that's gonna be hard for
you once the crowd at Disney's Resort in
Hawaii let out loud booze Lionel Richie
and Luke Bryan the other hosts stood up
and they were shocked at the audience
reaction they were like oh my God Katie
got booed it's the first time in six
seasons
Katie then responded what I'm saying is
I'd like to see you flip the script I
think we want to be pulled in by our
hearts too I'd love to see that and
America might too it just feels like
Katy Perry like this girl did a good job
and I haven't seen the performance feels
like the girl did a good job and Katie
like needed to critique her on something
and so it was like you need a new outfit
which is just like a low blow is she
trying to be Simon Cowell it's giving
Simon Cowell energy well you know like
the last thing she was criticized for
there was a contestant who I think she
had like um I think she had a lot of
kids or something and Katie mentioned
something about her you know spending a
lot of time on her back like it was
really kind of crazy she's been saying
some out-of-pocket [__] so here's the T
on KT tell us I interviewed her at
serious years ago when she was like just
starting but big big big big and she had
such a tune on her really she came in
and it was for Cosmo Radio and so my
co-host was a man and she was like
what's this penis doing in here oh God I
think she thought she was being funny
but she was being rude yeah and then she
was like she came for me I cannot
remember what it was but she was like
she was just be oh she's making fun of
my voice the quality of my voice but
like not in like in a fun way like Nelly
Furtado was like I like the girl with
the crazy voice yeah yeah but like Katie
was like how many how many packs of
cigarettes you smoke a day and at the
time how many packs of cigarettes three
and a half three and a half and so but
like she was just very like a abrasive
is the only word I can use and I don't
think she meant to be malicious but she
just like sucked yeah and she left and
we were like Ugh never again so I feel
like she has that energy she's kind of
like a nerdy show-off where she like
thinks she's being funny but she's
actually being mean precisely and I
think actually I can understand that
because I feel like a lot of my comedy
is like I poke fun at people and I poke
fun at myself yes but you have to know
like when you've crossed line and when
she's in like such a position of power
and he's American Idol things where it's
like you criticizing a young girl's
outfit when you're probably like one of
these young girls Role Models truly and
whatever she was trying to say maybe
it's like this girl does the same thing
every week maybe you could say it
without just being so explicit like
maybe next week I'd love to see you more
stripped down you know like in a simple
outfit with a simple song and we could
just [__] like there's a way to say
whatever she was trying to say but it
sounds like actually just wanted to have
like something original and creative to
say she ended up going for the girls
outfit well also like the voice which is
their number one competition I presume
they're nice yeah the voice is so good
and I like it I think we used to live in
a time where like being an [__] was
actually like encouraged I mean I was
encouraged to be one I felt it's serious
but now and like you actually have
inspired me to be like a way softer and
nicer and more of a fangirl because like
being a fan is cool yeah it used to be
cool to like be too cool exactly yeah so
maybe Katy Perry is like living in the
past Katy Perry's definitely having some
sort of identity crisis I think she has
been like since birth but she also went
through like a really rough time with
the pixie cut and she's definitely she's
back playing the haircut I blame the
haircut I think everyone does no
everyone when Anne Hathaway went through
her like terrible period She had a pixie
cut wow I never realized there is a
correlation between like being
universally disliked and having a pixie
cut
and you cannot convince me otherwise
ready for our fifth and final story yes
I am it's a little book news Taylor are
you a reader no right what do you think
no no why not I can't read good okay
well I guess you won't be reading this
Serena Williams is allegedly writing a
memoir post retirement yeah I won't the
retired tennis grade is shopping a
memoir sources page six that she could
be offered a hit Beyond 10 million
dollars
a publishing Insider said that the book
world is buzzing that Serena is selling
a memoir via power agent Suzanne Gluck
at WME and they speculate that there is
about an eight-figure deal on the table
a Second Source shares that a deal may
have already closed and that Williams
team was initially looking at offers for
multiple books Reps for Serena Williams
to not get back to them
um she has previously published a book
in 2009 called My Life queen of the
court she wrote that with a ghost writer
since the book came out she's hit
numerous new professional highs like she
married um Alexis Ohanian she became a
mom and she battled health issues so on
Monday Williams launched a multimedia
production company called 926
Productions which reportedly already has
a first look TV deal so she created a
Production Studio that will then adapt
her own book into a TV series for Amazon
Studios she's a very smart businesswoman
now that I'm into I love Serena Williams
I would totally read her book I will
read excerpts when it is written about I
will read the articles on page six does
that give you the yes the highlights um
but I love her another one I interviewed
a series and so wonderful really then
wonderful I just met her once and like
got a photo with her and it's so sad
because I've told the story before it's
the probably on in the history of photos
I've ever taken the ugliest photo I've
oh that's the worst it's really really
bad that's the worst um I'll show it to
you later I and I've spoken about it on
the chosen people want to see have you
never shared I posted it with an emoji
over my face like I I come on no Taylor
you can do it no I can it is how
I'll show you and then you'll understand
okay fine I'll show you after the show
um having said that she was a doll and I
love her and I wrote my everyone is like
Claudia we've heard the story I'm being
you like I'm telling the story of Rita I
wrote my college dissertation on Serene
Williams like I know everything about
her and I really love her like she's so
I'm really excited for this book
um the movie that came out Will Smith
I'm blanking um uh King Richard King
Richard it was the I literally I've
never said this before I was watching
with Tate and I was like I hope this
movie never runs I just want to keep
watching it because like I love the
girls and I love their relationship with
their dad I if I was going to read a
book this would be the one got it very
interesting and I love a celebrity
Memoir people go so deep and I feel like
Serena is probably like she's in a very
elite level of celebrity she's very I
wouldn't even say Ayla she's above that
because she's like with the Obamas you
know she's a totally very upper echelon
and she's notoriously private and I feel
like she runs in Fab I mean her wedding
was like crazy star-studded yeah Meghan
Markle Beyonce so so I feel like we'll
get a lot of good stuff in this book
because otherwise why would she write a
book right and then there's also just so
much about her coming up Venus and her
dad and you know competition stuff
that's beyond interesting but now she's
like for the last several years she has
been launched into a category of
celebrity I wouldn't even know what to
call it she's in the she's like in
another Stratosphere and I'm also
excited for the series because you know
if you can't read you can watch if you
can't read those who can't read watch
yes put it on my gravestone
um I think that this is my dream is to
people have seen me like read a book
about your life and I don't I mean
considering I don't read how why would I
want to write a book right but I'd write
it if I could then turn it into some
sort of like a series well you know what
I was writing a book and only then got
like I started to get into reading once
I started to write that makes sense I
was very anti-reading Jackie used to
come on here and be like I read this I
read that I'm like shut the [__] up
nobody cares no way yeah and then I was
like I really wanted to write a book and
I'm like well I don't really feel like I
can write a book if I don't read right
and I've always been into celebrity more
so I used to read a bunch of celebrity
Memoirs but I wasn't just a big reader
at all and I fell in love with reading
like it's my favorite I'll I'll read now
before I watch TV you know I used to
read maybe I'll get back into it my life
because Jackie convinced me she was like
you have to and I was like no no no no
no no and it has changed my life because
a it's just time spent off your phone
which is like just so bad for your
anxiety I know and at night it's good if
you want to fall asleep yes and it has
really changed my life and so I'm always
trying to convince other people like I
got Abe into reading he's obsessed now
and he's in my book club like uh I'm
trying to get Remy to read because I
know Remy has like a lot of anxiety yeah
like her phone and social media
she bought a Kindle and she hasn't made
any progress yet but I feel like re and
also being on tour there's so many hours
on Planes Trains so true just sitting in
dressing rooms on tour I Read 50 books
okay last year when I was on tour I read
60 books what should I start with oh
okay well
tell me what our interests are what are
you looking for the last like books I
remember reading guys Taylor has to read
the seven husbands of Evelyn Hugo that
will be the book that we'll get you into
is it like I like Thriller Vibes it I
don't want to spoil a single thing for
you but just like sexiness will you
trust me that you will love this book
I will trust you you guys write in the
comments and tell Taylor knowing what
you know about Taylor how much and by
the way it was a lesbian book no no no
no no no say it one more time no it is a
book it is glamorous it is old Hollywood
you will no no no no no trust me
trust me like Marilyn Monroe no you will
be sobbing by the end of this book
no you killer you guys will you leave a
comment and don't spoil it just be like
Taylor trust Claudia on this you will
love this book if you've read the book
it has also been adapted for uh a film
okay so when it comes out you could be
like I read the book okay I love that
moment moral High Ground
um I will say this the last book I ever
read genuinely front to front to end was
this book called everyone worth knowing
it's by the same author who wrote Devil
Wears Prada oh I've read a bunch of her
books and I love her and but it's like
about a PR girl who like goes to live in
Ibiza yeah no it's trash and I loved it
okay so I read when life gives you
Lululemon
by that same author just made a noise
Jackie was like just get past the title
because it was so cringy and it's about
like these rich women who wear Lululemon
in Connecticut love it was amazing and
she like married a senator who leaves
her it's so good I love her I'm telling
you like that you will like reading I
know I know okay you've convinced me I'm
gonna get you a copy of this book
just try Ben and I are in a club
together women against literacy yep but
Ben actually during uh Yom Kippur when
we couldn't like read or any when we
couldn't um watch TV or be on our phones
right he picked up a book and he loved
it but he just never finished it but he
loved the book he gets it he just like
it's too busy okay I'm gonna get you a
copy of the book okay I'm in guys right
leave a comment telling Taylor she will
love this book
please and that's our show hi thank you
for being here I love you I love you you
know I'm always available guys Taylor
hosts um she's a weekly podcast called
Taste of Taylor so if you love the
smoker's cough and you can't get enough
of it it's a free podcast called Taste
of Taylor I'm on it a bunch Brian's on
it's stassi's on it she gets great
guests she does pop culture and she also
does a Daily Show just like the toast
she does an hour a day it's a patreon
show so it's 6.95 every month for an
episode every single day every single
day you have different co-hosts your
wife comes on yep it's really fabulous
I'm actually a patreon member myself I
listen to some episodes because I like a
lot of your co-hosts thank you I love
Andrea Lopez I know I know I told her
she's so excited um so it's uh
patreon.com the taylorstracker show so
the free podcast is called Taste of
Taylor and then the patreon show is
called the Taylor Striker show if you're
looking for someone to listen to after
the toast every day because you can't
get enough I love it I love you guys
thank you so much for listening to the
toast we are oh Margo's joining me
tomorrow Jackie's out again so Margo's
with me tomorrow and the people love
Margo her episode outperformed everyone
she's a star she really is and she knows
it too thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast the money Morning
Show don't forget to get your merch at
toastmatch.com we hope you guys have a
great day thanks for listening if you're
listening as a podcast podcast available
or whatever listening Spotify iTunes
starting a wickedly talented we are have
a great Thursday and we'll see you
tomorrow it's almost Friday love you
guys bye